don't swipe the aisles yeah oh no
careful around your eyes george i just
told you that
what an eating experience this has been
[Music]
my name is george moats and it's my job
to make sure that you
love hamburgers as much as i do
sometimes it gets lonely in this kitchen
so guess what we have today our very
first ever
in studio guest ready for this one
holy [ __ ]
it's shawn evans look at this
i made it i made it i feel like i'm in
the george world yes you are well you're
in my house literally yeah it's
literally in my house so this is our
home crewing like this is what goes on
here high budget high budget well we had
to do something it was the big our big
pivot during the pandemic we've got a
special menu plan for you today i'm
excited two burgers are you hungry i'm
so hungry ready to eat i thought about
burgers i was gonna make for you and i
thought well i'm gonna make one of my
favorite chicago burgers the cheddar
char classic but you already had that on
the show then i wanted to make uh one of
my all-time favorite illinois burgers
the lacy edge burger which i think i may
have made up that name oh i don't know
if i've had a lacie yet before you have
you've been to shoops oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so literally it hasn't you can
hold it up to the light and it's almost
you know see-through but it has this
beautiful lacy beefy what we call it
that takes me back yeah that was a good
burger so i thought to myself okay
illinois
i mean it is it is a burger rich state
for sure no question about it so i
thought okay
what about the horseshoe sandwich
that would be new you don't know the
horseshoe i don't know the horseshoe
from springfield illinois okay
springfield which is that's the capital
of illinois chef joe schweska invented
this burger a hundred years ago so
probably in the mid-20s late 20s there's
a hotel called the leyland hotel
it's a very basic burger there's four
ingredients it's a plate it's an
open-faced hamburger sandwich originally
it was made with a piece of ham that was
cut in the shape of a horseshoe did you
know that
and on top of that are french fries the
fries represent the nails in the
horseshoe cool and on top of that is a
glorious
cheese sauce
now not just any cheese sauce this is
actually joe schweska's original 100
year old cheese sauce i mean this cheese
sauce is not a hundred years old i just
made it this morning but
but it's a real deal yes it is serious
comfort food so ready to do this i'm
ready to do it first toast you need two
slices a big thick toast look at that
okay
sorry
like my toaster yeah it's great i love
everything about your spot
i have a lot of toys it's not just like
a you know like a
cheap ass
you know yellow cheese sauce from like a
fast food or gas station right this is
this is a very
wise sauce it has worcestershire it has
some cayenne pepper it has some dry
mustard it's a great sauce it smells
like i was going to go get some crappy
[ __ ]
you know but about me red carpet yeah
red carpet okay smash your patty oh yeah
okay good
way off whoa okay let it sit for 20
seconds or so okay put some salt down
there right okay
we're gonna turn over so we have that
little cooked patch to the patch
that little cooked path prevents it from
sticking
to the spatula okay
okay oh
sorry it's almost like you're a brick
laying but you want to go down and off
to the right and then down and off to
the left okay don't hit too hard you
just nice like finesse going through the
first one yeah yeah
he looked nervous you see that he looked
nervous i did okay here we go so
straight down right
like that see that and you want to you
want to see it come out the other side
see and lift off right so that's only
one side the other side
the other side you want to turn i got a
little more on this side but then don't
hit it again done that's it all right
that there was some technique though
that was the other technique i actually
learned a technique from a guy in
watching a guy in st louis that carl's
driving
they go get her man
use the spatula
there you go you got it though other
side now
yeah
okay whoa i think i might have lost oh
i'll fix it i can fix it
yeah the difference is that i've done i
mean i did i did over 50 of these on
saturday so
really yeah
yeah what you've done a great job there
we go it's pretty good pretty good now
oh see what's happening there see that
yeah yeah yeah yeah that is a little
lace that's right oh there you go all
right no cheese on top normally i'd put
cheese on the flip not here
we're gonna get here that's right i'm
gonna throw it at you don't worry it's
time and then the top of this
we gotta have our nails those are nails
right horseshoe with nails
the glorious welsh rare bit
wow
you ready i'm ready let's already take
one of these
how'd you go first
do you just dive in with hands that
would be more illinois
all right so this is the george
experience i can tell hot off the
[ __ ] hot right [ __ ] hot hot as
hell but
it wouldn't be uh it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be better
if i didn't
set my mouth on fire
was it good
i've done about this burger for a long
time but it took a few fan requests to
get it on the show wow and just the
right guess for you and for you and just
the right guess
on to the next burger
let's do this
the horseshoe was an homage to your home
state
illinois right ill but now i want to
expand your burger horizons right a
little bit we've done this burger on the
show but we used a mild green chili
that's right it's the green chili
cheeseburger
we did something very special for you
sean we got some extra hot hatch green
chilies
now
just i'll just i'll be
totally up front with you yeah i'm a
spice wimp
okay i actually fear you're going to ask
me on your show that i realized i wasn't
famous enough but
because of the climate in new mexico
green chile is indigenous to the state
you can find it in parts of southern uh
colorado and parts of western texas but
it's pretty much indigenous only to new
mexico it's a very special pepper okay
let's call jalapeno a slap in the face
green chili is kind of like a punch in
the gut because it goes whoa that's
really tasting great and then it whoa
yeah so i know that's green chili first
i'm going to toast the buns
wow
burgers you want to smash again yeah
there you go and then roll over we're
going to roll it oh roll oh close roll
off like that there you go yeah buddy oh
it's a little you made a horseshoe it
looks like uh
it looks like the state of maine it does
look at this
oh [ __ ]
i just got i just got dunked on it okay
green chili on now this is
extra hot hatch yeah that's a that's a
healthy spoonful right there well if
you're in new mexico this is how you do
it this is half of what they would
normally use really oh yeah chili went
on first then the cheese on second
hovered up to melt it the melting trick
the sound of melting
cheese
sorry it's okay everything's fine
what these guys want me to do
is put a little bit of last dab on mine
yeah that would be great i think you
should
i want to see the shake
look at this
[Laughter]
oh give that a smile
it has a nice smell oh wow
oh
that's fruity i think i just glossed out
my nose here
now
let's lit it with our little crown
this is a classic
new mexican green chili cheeseburger
oh [ __ ] mm-hmm
yeah feel it
are you trying to spread as i am there
you are
wow right
so green chili
it has a slow launch yeah no i'm i'm
riding it yeah i'm just like riding that
wave
wow though oh
and like a really hot that's [ __ ] hot
it is [ __ ] hot and then it's good
though right it is good and i think
that's always the
culinary needle to thread when you're
making something
that's spicy is that yeah it becomes a
labor of love because you can't put it
down you just have to go for another
bite
look thank you hold up oh god
okay fine
give me a shake man the people want it
george who want it i know you want it
people fine i'll do it
okay okay
hold on there we go
that's okay
[Music]
motion is not a good idea
pray for george
oh a ham yeah wow oh my god
oh wow that's a well that's similar to
the green chili it's like a very slow
blast and similar to the green
[ __ ] oh my god this that's definitely a
throat scratch is my nose running
i think my nose is ready there you go oh
milk thank you here you go george
that's good it's not helping
the crazy thing about hot pepper is that
it does do things to you that you can't
control
right you can't control with that i
can't control this habit i'm sorry i
can't control my sweat you can't
complain okay what is what am i what am
i saying it's flying off the rails
bill get a close-up quick before i die
jesus
can't go away i'm trying to take another
bite it's not gonna [ __ ] help am i
sweating
oh my god look at this
don't swipe the eye oh yeah oh yeah yeah
we so what we just did was
we put two different spices together and
it worked kind of
come on
don't tell me what to do
it's my show
what an eating experience
yeah i'm alive i'm alive
i'm alive
i'm going to be okay
eat the butter
you know
oh the help it actually helps
oh that helps
whoa why does that work
people
butter helps
me cheers here cheers cheers sean thanks
for being on the show
george thanks so much for having me it's
it's been a dream of mine for for you to
cook me some burgers you you brought me
back to illinois and then you topped it
off by uh this circus act at the end
dabbing on our
dabbing on our santa fe burgers thanks
for making me dab i appreciate that hey
yeah
next time burger boys spicy boys
milk down in one
[Music]
hi i'm george moats from burger scholar
sessions don't forget to like and
subscribe and watch more episodes right
here
somewhere here
right here
up in here